turns out dana's dog's a stoner
wow just like his owner yeah dana's dog
wouldn't keep up the grass and ended up
stoned off his ass
last week dana's dog percy had to go to
the hospital after he accidentally ate
some edibles marijuana off the ground in
central park terrible in an unrelated
story kat lost her purse in central park
[Music]
dana rushed percy to the vet after
getting this video from the doggy
daycare
[Music]
oh man poor kid
all jokes aside especially that joke of
a story about how the edible must come
from the park and not the disgusting
drug den that dana lives in
but weed can make dogs pretty sick the
animal poison control center claims that
calls about pets eating weed are up
765 percent
since 2019. although it's rarely fatal
vets say it can cause symptoms like
difficulty walking wobbling while
sitting still
shaking vomited dilated pupils and
incompetence or as julie banderas calls
it monday morning
dana i know we're making a lot of this
but i feel terrible for the dog cause
the dog doesn't know what's happening he
doesn't know well maybe that's good yeah
right i mean uh if it's good i
have to say that i for a moment i
thought my dog was going to die yeah
he's four and a half months old he's
only 25 pounds and he couldn't walk and
all these things now that i know that it
was marijuana i don't think i would have
been in a panic thinking he was going to
die what i didn't know is apparently
dogs have different receptors in their
brain so when the cannabis goes into
their brains it makes them very crazy
town so he had to spend a night in a
hospital
and uh
have an iv to flush it all out and but
it was interesting is as soon as i
posted about it and said i wanted to do
a segment i got so many notes and one of
them was a very supportive one from kat
and you know people that this happened
to you and it was like all these
messages that happened to my dad
happened to my cousin so we had a vet on
that said here's what you do in case it
happens first but also just like don't
throw it on the ground yes it's not like
a cookie yeah that's true right right
yeah it's better than a cookie
um
really a lot better dana what if he got
hooked on and liked it what if he came
home and he's listened to like reggae
and demanding you know
munchies and writing monologues right
yes yes
cat how is your dog still alive
don't ask me
because yeah it's tough because they're
dumb i mean he never he's never eaten
weed he ate a bunch of my cats
once
he did and clumping litter and he had to
spend the night in the hospital because
it clumps up in your organs you can die
he's he's done but he's still alive as
far as i know i'll see when i get home
um
anything else also i'd never leave a bag
full of drugs in the purse yeah and in
the park yeah you never bring more out
than you need yeah it's a very good
point in case you lose it yeah that's
that it's one of the you learned that in
eighth grade
[Laughter]
todd i uh twice now you've said to me
you don't want to you don't you don't
feel comfortable discussing this look i
am anti-poisoning of dogs me too i am
running on that platform as well fox in
every classroom don't poison puppies
okay someone who poisons puppies would
say that though because everyone just
assumes you don't want to poison a
people yeah a child molester would say
oh i just coached little league
but tyrus i i should have called in
tyrus if i found the person who left the
world that's the thing how do you put
how can you find the tyrus how do you
punish the person i mean how do you
you're never gonna find the person i
gotta be honest with you greg i misread
this story completely uh i was so
excited i was in my office today going
dana preno smokes weed
we have so much in common now and i had
so many fun jokes and
now when she talked about the iv and
thought her dog was gonna die i was like
that's so funny i can't say anything
that i worked so hard to say today i
will say this
if you are going to and i think i can
speak for tyros and tim podcast
if you're going to
introduce your dog or cat or fish to
marijuana
we don't condone it but if you must
you blow the smoke
in the nose or the mouth and then they
have a great time like but just like
people serious just
no just like people
edibles are hard
to measure yes they are and if you take
too much you get sick it's not just dogs
it's all of us sometimes we don't listen
to our dealer or prescription and
if you take too much you end up under
the bed a scared of the dark yeah so
again i'm sorry i completely misread
this oh yeah so my that hey gene put the
banner dana smokes weed away please
another thing would you ask me if it was
mine well the only other thing i thought
was peter had a hell of a good story
that's all i thought was like yes dear
it must be the part because to be honest
with you when you drop weed you pick it
up
that's a good point too i think we
solved nothing nothing at all and i got
to read the whole story yes coming up is
being cold on a date the way to attract
a mate